today I'm talking about my favorite
chick favorite celebrity lizzo lizzo
lizzo lizzo so who is lizzo you don't
know I'm sure most people do she is an
International world-renowned Celebrity
so lizzo I've really been listening to
since I was in high school and I
actually used to be a really big fan of
lizzo I think she's a really talented
artist I think it's really crazy how she
can move with all the weight she's got
but the last couple of years I really
started listening to her music a bit
more and listening to the lyrics and
really paying a little bit closer
attention to her on social media and
she's really been one of the pillar
celebrities of the body positive
movement this woman has been putting her
flab on the internet lizzo actually
threatened to quit music Imagine doing
something for 10 15 years threatening to
quit music and locks her Twitter account
after the latest wave of body shame